why do you think it is that people have
the wrong impression when you do bring
up death that people they think okay if
you talk about death
it's just something so gloomy it's it's
gloom its doom it's like I don't want to
hear about it either someone will make a
joke they'll get kind of really
uncomfortable and they'll change the
subject and even some Muslims like when
you say you bring it up they're like
come on you're messing up my mood should
that be the attitude definitely not
because again this is why people are
just putting things off when it's coming
towards them it's like again you'll you
a person sitting by the train track and
the train is coming and he doesn't want
to face the reality that it's coming
it's gonna hit you so this is why as
Muslims we were ordered in the Quran and
in the Sunnah of the Prophet SAW Selim
to be real and death the subject of
death should not make us miserable
should actually make us have more
reality to this life to have the real
happiness in it if a person frequently
remember death he would the things that
really enjoyable in this life you will
enjoy it which is the obedience of Allah
even the permissible acts the things
that people enjoy as human beings will
enjoy it if we do it for the sake of
Allah with without committing sins and
this will being a loss final time loss
pilot Allah even mentioned death in the
context of verses that talks about the
favours of Allah as if death is a favor
of Allah for some individuals if they
understand death in the proper way as
mentioned also before in solar term and
saluted Menelaus panel Tala mention in
it many verses shall be a year later
become a token event which one of the
favours of Allah would you deny so it
talks about the favours of Allah but
within the solar it says Kulemin an
eiephant each and every one on its
meaning on the face of earth will vanish
will die well how would you Arabic I
don't deny the winning column and only
the face of your Lord would stay meaning
allah subhanaw taala is a high
he's the everliving everybody will die
so this is mentioned in the context of
verses talking about the favours of
Allah so for the believers and it's only
for the believers it's a favor from
Allah and they depart from the miseries
of this life to the everlasting joy and
that's also the prophets are sallam said
that that when a Jenelle's are passed by
and
are you so to send the meaning of which
either this is something in most area
how most allahö mean even he is relaxing
he's comfortable or the world is relaxed
as a result of his death because he was
a someone that is spreading corruption
and so on so either or
so therefore the believers they they go
to the to the comfort zone after the
death they don't wish for it of course
because it is against our innate and our
nature but what happens if they were
believers and steadfast upon the deen of
allah and repented told us a note Allah
they will go to the real comfort not
this life this life is not comfortable
thing for them this statement have you
heard it and what is him how would you
explain it where people who often hear
it said that people are asleep they're
sleeping in this life until death comes
then they awake right this is a true
statement that actually some other
origination same dimension this people
are not flat they're asleep they're
intoxicating themselves but is it a kind
of like a spiritual sleep it's the it's
the sleep where a person is not aware of
what's coming ahead okay and people when
they think of death as you said it's
something gloomy as if it's not real
it's the opposite people would see that
this life was a delusion hmm and when
the moment of death comes it's more real
than this life it's more real and
clearer than the fact that we're sitting
and looking each other and talking that
is not something cloudy or something
that is not needed so just some Souls
and things like this that people know
this is more reality than the fact that
we're living and eating and tasting and
so on and that's what Allah Spanos Allah
says in the Quran in surah kahf that
when death comes were Jets a crow two
notable Hawk Valley comic-con Tomino the
hidden when the stubborn or the stopper
of Death Comes the miseries and agony of
death comes this is what you used to
avoid in your life and then it says like
a chef's knife a besouro Colima hadith
your cover will be lifted and your
eyesight will be hadid is like iron that
means your eyesight will be as nothing
before it's more reality more awakening
than anything else
Wow so then we're working to be awake a
person who is
using his logic knowing that everything
is deteriorating and the human being
I mean we've spent at some time apart
and you can just you mentioned you know
the the amount of people that have died
just every day they were that are in
this life we're in this life they're
going somewhere and Islam gives you the
blueprint and tells us have you come
across any other way of life that goes
over the details from when the Angel of
Death Comes to when Death Comes to what
goes on after that everything is laid
out because that would be unjust if the
Creator didn't tell us these things but
he's warned us he's given us the answers
to the test I have not come across and
I'm a student of comparative religion
looking at the other religions and for
the sake of Dawa but have you come
across anything other than Islam that
lays out such a detailed explanation of
the details of death and the Hereafter
there's no such a thing as the you would
find in the Quran and this one of the
Prophet SAW said Allah that makes it
really very clear and it's it is very
something that as we find in the
verbatim our God the Quran and the
friend up from the Prophet Muhammad
example no right there's nothing but
like no because this is the final
revelation from Allah Sanatana the most
comprehensive and anything that we need
to know from the hereafter that would
make our life according to Allah spinal
Tala wants from us he would find it
explained in so much teachings have have
you ever heard this this argument so
much says I'll deal with it when it
happens hmm well this is maybe can work
in matters of this world that we live in
and sometimes it's true when the person
is concerning himself about something
that is there is no need for him to be
concerned about it now wordly things
materialistic things but when it comes
to the purpose of our life there's no
such a thing as I'll deal with it later
later meaning in this and Hereafter
there's no actions to be done it's only
he said reckoning and today is actions
and there's no reckoning there's no
punishment yet or a reward in this life
so when the moment of death comes the
person would wish to come back to fix
what he made of mistakes but it's too
late and that's also mentioned the Quran
so that nobody would regret the
the regret is already explained in the
Koran some verses in the film when you
recite them that talks about person
dying and you would see a lot
build-your-own oh my lord let me return
back you would feel when you're
reflecting upon these verses you put
yourself in that situation so you feel
regretful as if you are in that
situation so you would face the reality
that it's not there yet
so let me do something before I regret
so the Quran gives us clear instructions
and ways so that we do not regret we
were discussing in the message today and
for the past few days
solo dr. Han Solo - table at Terrebonne
means the loss and gain that people have
in their buying and selling imagine
someone a child has a diamond the most
expensive one he would go to sell it for
a candy bar he doesn't know the value of
it so if someone exchanged something
very very valuable for something that
has no value whatsoever he would feel
that great loss people would be like
this in the EFT when they see that the
matter was so easy for them to be to
receive the general philosophy no dad it
was so easy to be obedient to Allah but
they wasted it for what for temporary
joy that it's not really doing the
believers are more joyful actually in
this life than those who are
intoxicating themselves in theirs